Rạn sáng nay hai mi trình tăng sấu, máy bay et bất à bà năng gui của hẳn hàng không buộc gà bên năm để nào em lại.
Trởi một trong hai mi tự cán bộ trên sĩ thuộc bộ cuối phòng và bộ công an.
Công hăng chục tấn trang thiết mi, quân thiện chuyên dụ, chống như buộc, hàng ngoá khu vụ công tác thêm kiếm kiếm nạn,
khổ chựng nhân đạo đã cất cảnh từ cản hàng không có thể nổi hay.
Lên đường tới về này, rồi là thực hiện giảm vụ hỗ trợ khách vụ hộ phụ hộ quả trực đúng rất nghiêm chọc, chứ dờ khởi hành,
những cái bác tay cùng lời đồng viên dặng giò của lãnh đạo hai mộ đã tích thêm niềm tin và quyết tâm cho các thành viên trong đoàn.
Chế hành trình đặc biệt này, mỗi cán bộ trên sĩ đều mang trên vai một nhận vự khu thêm.
Nhưng hôm thế, họ còn đại diễn cho hình ảnh một Việt Nam nhân ảy chất nhiều luôn sẵn sàng sát cánh sẽ chia và chúng tai cùng bạn bài khu tế,
vượt qua những thời khá khó khăn.
L'hoc các hoạc, chuyến bây giờ sẽ qua cạnh tại sân bay, bà đi rao ở đây gó liên.
Bộ pháp, còn ngày hai mì chỉ tháng sáng 5 theo dưới được quân.
Chúc hình tự tổc hành trình đường sân bài ảnh rô bị chế lên nâng vinh này dưới lã.